[Applause]
[Music]
combat talk ah hi welcome to combat talk
people right now we got Manny Pacquiao
vs. Lucas mateesah i'ma tell you right
now I really don't believe Lucas metier
say has the heart for this fight but I
believe he's the bigger man in his fight
with the stronger punch at this get late
time in the game I believe Manny
Pacquiao has lost a step and in this
fight he's going to need absolutely
every last drop of his speed to beat
Lucas mateesah if he can get inside me
Lucas mateesah make the fight go a
little bit longer I think he can pile up
the punches and actually stop Lucas he
stayed to the body
now if the TSA catches Pacquiao cold I
think he can drop him flat we've all
seen Manny Pacquiao caught cold all
right and he he doesn't play any games
and he goes to sleep he goes to sleep
show officially so um my actual
prediction for this fight Pacquiao by
TKO in the ninth round it's gonna
probably drop him with a body shot
somewhere in the fifth or sixth round
pile up the punches Lucas would probably
swell up around the eyes try to be stop
ninth round thank you ha first combat
talk love it
[Applause]
[Music]